oui mérité dit s'éjecta compris
les spectateurs qui nous regarde moi je
vous le dis je parle à beaucoup de temps
et beaucoup de gens me disent moi les
enfants jamais mais voilà tout le
mondial a plein qui le disent dont
sandrine mère de quatre enfants qui a
très peur du vaccin et de l'avenir de
ses enfants pourraient le rendre la
vaccination obligatoire pour les enfants
sur un vrai drame et se passe à une
terre est catastrophique vous avez
quatre enfants de quel âge et ben 10
depuis hier pour un as et 12 non 11
rebonds ça commence vous connaissez vos
enfants
oui bien sûr après j'ai 16 et 30 ans
dacquois 30 ans à vide est encore la
maison non
alors donc vous avez peur parce que là
vous êtes concernés oui deux pour deux
nuits alors pourquoi qu'est ce qui vous
fait peur moi je sais pas en fait c'est
qu' il est encore expérimentale ce
vaccin en fait on sait pas du tout ce
qui va y avoir dans quelques années on
sait pas dans quel état vont être nos
enfants moi il est hors de question que
cette valse vaccin viennent sur sur le
sait vous avez peur oui
ne vous a jamais expliqué qu'on gêne
avec le recul j'ai des avis non je suis
désolé c'est le pillage et des amis mois
la mère de ma meilleure amie le
lendemain du vaccin embolie pulmonaire
le mak oleg sa fille se fait vacciner et
comme par hasard à la les problèmes
cardiaques faux au bout d'un moment on
se pose quand même pas mal de questions
maintenant dans dix ans qu'est ce qui va
se passer et les glandes qui poussent
sous les bras et tout ça il ya tout ça
j'ai eu aussi des allemands
balocco
beaucoup hésitent beaucoup en rêvent
vous avez peur en fait vous avez peur et
vous voyez des trucs mais oui c'est vrai
ils sont en fait qu'est-ce qu'elle fait
100 dinars a dream je me fais l'avocat
du diable je vous le dis voilà moi
qu'est ce qu'être c'est sandrine elle
fait comme plein de téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent elle calcule le
bénéfice-risque s10 moi mes enfants ils
sont très bonne santé oui
je vais prendre le risque peut-être de
le déterminer alors que pour la danse
tout va bien et là dans la vie ça va
c'est ce que tout le monde se dit alors
bien sûr vous allez me dire oui mais il
faut penser aux autres on comprend pas
mais c'est les gars là temps 12 10 ans
il faut arrêter là c'est normal et la
peur est la paix mais un moment et je
sais comment pensent les gens et on sait
que un moment on pense d'abord à ses
enfants je vous le dis et que ses
enfants on se dit peut-être moi je veux
bien prendre le risque de faire vacciner
mais pour les enfants j'ai pas très
envie non plus donc à plein de gens qui
se disent à un rythme un moment c'est
pas non plus c'est pas des fous qui se
disent assez du des personnes qualifiées
sans silva qui ont peur pour les enfants
c'est juste pour les enregistrer maxi
mes parents ils ont du mal à sauter le
pas matthieu delormeau qui est vous avez
des enfants
je les ignore mais
c'est comme ça sinon on al impression qu
est le méchant gouvernement qui veut une
valve le vaccin et puis elle est il est
gentil ou qui va faire paniquer les
mélangeant qui en accueillent tous
parlent que je me posais la question
quel serait l'intérêt du gouvernement
est de nous faire vacciner les enfants
s'il y avait un risque quelconque quelle
serait la
journée
comme dans les chaînes enfoncé vraiment
j'ai bien parlé que je me suis dit
c'était ce que j'aurais dit non jean
michel cohen arrigoni avec la société
saba on nous a dit au départ l'astra
zeneca et aucun problème why allez
apprendre nous allier à banon n'ont
finalement non c'est on va pour les
sites à plus de 50 sont prises si sa
cote
chez les plus de 50 ans
bon d'accord d une autorisation après
le fade et gone a atteint quand je cours
soit qu'elles aient peur mais on ya
tellement d'informations à propos du
vaccin à l'heure actuelle que je
consomme avec alan b